[Musique]
ouassini c'est un morceau de corail
tombé dans l'océan à la frontière
maritime du kenya de la tanzanie par
dessus un village de pêcheurs pas de
porc à wassigny pas de route ni voiture
ni même une seule bicyclette pas
d'électricité pas d'eau courante pas
beaucoup d'hommes ce qui reste pêche un
peu ou promènent le touriste autour de
l'île quand il y en a dont beaucoup sont
en ville loin parti pour la semaine pour
le mois alors que reste-t-il à ou s il y
des femmes est un trésor
leurs trésors le jardin de corail
a plongé un massif de corail dans une
mer bien chaude
laissez gonfler quelques milliers
d'années à baisser le niveau des océans
fait le polir et raboté par le
va-et-vient des marais encore quelques
milliers d'années tapissent le fond
d'algues vertes et voilà c'est servi un
paysage unique de coraux pétrifié dans
un jardin entouré de mangrove ce qui
nous a poussé à faire ce projet autour
du jardin kooren c que l'on avait
remarqué que les touristes qui passaient
était fasciné par ces rochers en forme
d'animaux alors on a commencé par
surveiller ces coraux afin qu'ils ne
soient plus détruites ou abîmées
un trésor ça se pie ix
c'est fait pour longtemps les gens de
wassigny se sont servis du corail comme
pierre à bâtir de la mangrove comme bois
de chauffe ou de construction
le jardin a bien failli disparaître
[Musique]
alors les fondatrices du groupe on sait
il ya des touristes qui viennent qui
visitent le jardin et repart et nous on
reste là avec nous soucier à ne pas
pouvoir envoyer nos enfants à l'école ni
même à joindre les deux alors on a remis
en était le lieu on a nettoyé les coraux
du matin au soir
un jardin de corail c'est déjà pas mal
pour un touriste mais quand en plus une
semaine par mois
la mère surgi des mangroves rampe et
inondent le jardin que les grandes
marées engloutissent les coraux alors là
ouassini c'est versailles
[Musique]
si bien qu'un jour pour mieux faire
profiter les touristes de leur jardin
extraordinaire
les femmes de wassigny ont eu une idée
construire un pont temps un ponton pour
marcher sur l'eau entre ces cailloux aux
formes étranges un ponton pour se
promener sans se perdre dans la mangrove
qui l'entourent ponton payant 100
shillings la visite 1 euro avec son
visiteur on aurait vite rempli les
caisses du village pour un mois tu vois
comme ici c'est dangereux
cette planche là elle est pourrie elle a
besoin de préparer les rien à sauver
il regarde celle ci la sso s'il faut
tout refaire
khadija et beauté c'est son vrai nom qui
sont un peu chefs sont toujours envoyés
en éclaireuse quand il ya un pépin
or depuis quelques temps le ponton leur
ponte va mal
dacquoise et pour dire la vérité c'est
très dangereux de laisser le ponton dans
cet état si on louvre touristes ce qui
ne marche pas bien on est sûr de les
voir se casser la figure
l'autre jour des visiteurs n'ont même
pas pu se promener l'eau passait par
dessus le pont qu'ils il faut absolument
le renflouer par endroits donc il faut
qu'on s'active
c'est juste que notre situation
financière n'est pas bonne en ce moment
mais en comptant sur la prochaine saison
une seule là on y arrivera faut dire
qu'elles ont vu grand les femmes de
wattignies très très grand elle se
voyait déjà en haut de la fiche du
bureau du tourisme du kenya
venez voir le plus grand ponton
d'afrique de l'est
ils sont venus les touristes au début
cinquante par jour
payant leurs 100 shillings mais les
émeutes de 2007 au kenya les ont fait
fuir tout cela laisse aujourd'hui aux
entrepreneurs de wassigny le plus grand
ponton de toute l'afrique de l'est à
entretenir
[Musique]
à chaque fois qu'un problème se pose au
groupe des femmes de wattignies paf
c'est la séance plénière où ça sur le
ponton évidemment qu'il a - encore moins
d'argent que nous rapporte ce projet on
le partage en fin d'année une part pour
les bourses scolaires ont près la moitié
des frais pour chaque enfant une part
pour compléter le salaire des
enseignants chaque mois on a
ah et on aide aussi l'école religieuse
on donne pour les fêtes du village
quand il ya un problème les gens
viennent nous voir et si on peut nous
les aidons quelques heures plus tard
john nash charpentier est convoquée sur
le ponton beauté khadija s'improvise
maître d'ouvragé et chef de chantier
non c'est juste la question de se mettre
d'accord
une fois d'accord sur le prix je sais ce
que je dois faire y'a pas de soucis je
creuse des trous pour les pieux du
ciment aujourd'hui c'est ça le boulot
c'est pas la question a besoin de parler
swahili pour comprendre ce qu'ils disent
khadija la cliente et john les
charpentiers temps de vie est trop chère
mais ma pauv'dame ça prend du temps un
chantier comme ça il ya peut-être moyen
de faire plus simple et cetera bref
khadija la cliente veut que ça commence
tout de suite et john le charpentier
manque de bras alors on s'arrange
toutes les femmes du groupe de wassigny
mène une double vie
activiste le jour simple ils viennent le
soir comme khadija leur présidente élue
pour deux ans un mari parti plusieurs
mois sur le continent
deux enfants à élever
sahim american hazard lille avant ou ne
se soucie pas les uns des autres où
vivait et côte à côte
et c'est vrai que depuis cette histoire
de pontons un centre aide avant les
joies ne sortez pas de chez eux
maintenant où seront visibles on se
retrouve et on sort de notre île même
dans des programmes
des porcs
quand on fait partie du groupe des
femmes de wassigny il faut savoir
mouiller son sari exemple la mangrove
elle pousse pas tout seul enfin si mais
mieux encore si on plante les goûts bien
droite dans la vase et allaman alors une
fois par quinzaine ces corvées de goose
[Musique]
n'allez pas croire pour autant qu'au
village sans prétention les femmes et
bonne réputation
prenez tashi par exemple c'est l'un des
rares pêcheurs à pied de wassigny encore
autorisés à travailler dans la mangrove
oui car les femmes limite la prédation
sur cette zone fragile en bordure du
ponton pêcheurs exclusif presque tache y
sont succulents crabes des mangroves
ils ont nourri ces dix enfants et dès
que le touriste se pointe le vent bien 4
euros le kilo ce serait très mal si les
mangroves n'existait plus j'aurais pu
quitter l'île de nim avis pêcheurs ou
changer de métier mais ingratitude de
pêcheurs dès qu'il s'agit du ponton des
femmes ce projet il se bat bien pour ça
c'est ce qui me chagrine chez ces femmes
c'est qu'elle devrait quand même trouvé
des deux ou trois pour les guider car
tout seul regardez l'état du poteau
s'est pas entretenu c'est mal gérée
comme ça s'est passé après le ragot des
mangroves
c'est john le charpentier qui nous joue
le ponton des soupirs la kanye west
le problème c'est qu'elle manque
d'ouverture d'esprit parce que leur
projet bon d'accord ça peut aider les
enfants du village
mais ça doit être solide financièrement
je crois qu'elle aurait besoin d'un bon
coach qui comprennent les sens de cette
affaire il faudrait qu'elles mettent
leurs maris d'un coup n'a atteint que
pourrais je sais pas faire du business
vendre des trucs tradicionales sur le
ponton non il ya plein de choses à faire
les femmes de wattignies ne sont pas
dupes c'est ce qui se raconte dans leur
dos au village à leur ponton qui prend
le wouri
leur trottoir à rien ni personne alors
le groupe des femmes à trouver un moyen
simple de lutter contre la
désinformation masculine la propagande
c'est aïcha institutrice infiltrés et
membre du groupe des femmes qui s'y
emploient au programme de son cours de
sciences naturelles
tiens comme par hasard la mangrove
aujourd'hui nous allons parler des
mangroves vous savez ce que c'est si
vous avez des questions vous demandez ça
mais quand à quoi ça sert les mangroves
c'est utile à quoi d'abord à empêcher
l'érosion du sol
et puis ça fournit à mabri et de quoi se
nourrir à des petites que tout poisson
la bad en aux mangroves
il ya aussi des cram des crevettes vous
savez ça au moins bas ces mondiaux à on
ne badine pas avec aïcha et quand vient
la fin du cours
jusqu'à l'heure de la récré on répète le
chant des partisans de la mangrove
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
beynat tout le monde connaît les
planches de deauville la promenade des
anglais le grand baie à saint malo les
remparts du mont-saint-michel banalité
maritimes n'ont changé les essayer donc
un jour le grand ponton du jardin de
corail des femmes de wassigny un euro
elles n'attendent que cela
[Musique]